super typhoon hog abyss made landfall
and is rushing towards the world's
largest urban area Tokyo severe weather
already has claimed the life of one man
and injured dozens more forecasters say
the typhoon could be the most dangerous
in more than 60 years darkened skies and
the roar of emergency vehicles on the
streets of Tokyo as super typhoon hog
abyss and nightfall approached central
Japan just across the narrow waters of
Tokyo Bay a tornado hit the city of Ichi
Hara one man was killed as winds
overturned his car several others were
injured as the twister ripped through
homes leaving empty shells on top of
damage from severe winds rain is
pounding the region hard Japanese
authorities issued a top-level emergency
rain warning for prefectures around
Tokyo authorities say there is an
extreme risk of landslides and the Japan
weather agency warns rainfall could
reach record levels the agency says hag
abyss is packing dangerous winds of 180
kilometers per hour and gusts of more
than 250 kilometers per hour millions of
residents have been told to evacuate
areas in the storm's path